[Musique]
champbertin Claude Vougeot roman et
Conti Corton Charlemagne montraché
impossible de citer tous les noms
prestigieux et enchanteurs qui bordent
la route des Grands cru ces trésors qui
font briller les yeux des amateurs de
vin du monde entier nous allons les
découvrir en compagnie d'un guide
passionné à bord d'une traction avant
datant de l'apré
guerre car la route des Grands cru cet
itinéraire mythique de la bourg vitico
fê cette année ces 80
ans ensemble nous allons suivre cette
route à la découverte de monuments
prestigieux plonger dans l'histoire
descendre dans des caves vieilles de
plusieurs siècles traverser des
centaines de climats inscrits au
patrimoine culturel mondial de
l'humanité et goûter le terroir de cette
terre bénie des
dieux
nous sommes sur la route des grandscu au
niveau du village de fissin cette route
des GrandCru est une route emblématique
puisqu'elle elle traverse les plus beaux
villages de la côte viticool côte
dorienne avec des noms tels que gevr
Chambertin V romané chambol musini pour
la côte de nuit ou encore Bernand
vergelaise pulini monrachet vol m pour
la côte de
Ba LEB est
guideouristique depuis des années il
empreunte régulièrement cette route avec
ses clients qui l'emmènne visiter le
vignoble et nous voilà ici dans le
centre du village de gevreet Chambertin
il y a neuf grands cru à gevreet
Chambertin sur les 33 que comportent la
Bourgogne cette route des Grands cru
elle est l'âme de la Bourgogne elle est
celle qui nous permet de nous retourner
vers notre passé de voir tous ces
vinerons qu' l'emprintent depuis des
siècles et qu' l'empreintte encore
aujourd'hui chaque jour pour produire
ces grands vin Bourgogne dont on est si
fier et qui sont connus dans le monde
entier d ces premers kilomètres la route
des Grands cru plonge dans l'histoire à
la sortie de gevreet Chambertin apparaît
le plus vieux CLA de Bourgogne le Claude
ba fondé en 632 par les moines de
l'abbaye du même nom un CLA est une
parcelle de vigne on appelle un climat
en Bourgogne et CLA vient du latin
cludéré qui veut dire fermé chaque
climat va donner un vin unique qui a un
goût qui représente la typicité du lieu
on disait vulgairement il faut que le
vin ait la gueule de l'endroit où il est
né écoutez la gueule de ce vinl vous
avez un vin qui est d'une grande
complexité du grande longueur en bouche
mais je crois que tout ça est finalement
à prendre avec des pincettes si vous me
permettez l'expression car le goût est
personnel à chacun d'entre nous en
fonction de sa propre histoire je dirais
simplement pour Gon rpnel il disait en
parlant du Claude be il est tout le
Grand Bourgogne
possible la route des Grands cru est la
plus ancienne route touristique viticole
de France elle est née en 1937 à
l'initiative du député maire de Dijon
Gaston
Gérard à l'époque les vignerons font
face à une crise économique sans
précédent
les années 30 c'est une période de crise
crise de surproduction crise de mvente
mais c'est aussi une période de
renouvellement un peu du vignoble
puisqu'on a une nouvelle forme de
commercialisation et de production des
vins qui est l'appellation d'origine
l'idée c'est de réaliser une
délimitation stricte des cru pour
pouvoir mieux les
vendre au 19e siècle on n pas
nécessairement obligé de faire du jeevra
chambbertin avec les jeevra chbertin on
le fait avec des raisins de chambau
musini des raisins des villages
alentours or après les appellations
d'origine on a obligation d'utiliser
uniquement des raisins de gevret
chambbertin donc on a une
territorialisation du vin qui est pas
innocente et qui va créer pour
l'acheteur l'idée qu'il existe un
terroir spécifique qui donne un goût
spécifique au
vin dès lors le vignoble de Bourgogne
jusque-l considéré comme une simple zone
de production de raisins pour les n
ciant devient un lieu touristique à part
entière on vient voir le terroir au même
titre que les grands monuments
historiques des villes de Dijon et
B la route c'est vraiment
l'aboutissement de cette construction de
ce qu'on appelle le folklore vineux on
va normer la gastronomie régionale ça va
aller avec les vins locaux c'est
l'invention du bœuf bourguignon des
escargot de bourgogne des ormerurettes
et cetera et tous ces plats là on les
retrouve dans les grandes festivités
folkloriques qui se met en place dans
les années 20 et 30 avec les chansons
bourguignones également le point d'or de
ces festivités c'est l'invention
finalement de la confrériie des
chevaliers du tadevin en 1934 et ces
inventions là paradoxalement vont créer
une mythologie et une espèce d'éternité
à la Bourgogne et c'est ça qui fait
finalement le succès de cette Bourgogne
et de cette première route des vins en
France elle invente un passé avec une
certaine
modernité
[Musique]
quelques kilomètres plus au sud planté
au milieu des vignes surgit un témoin
millénaire de l'histoire de la Bourgogne
le château du
claudeevougeot classé monument
historique il accueille chaque année
plus de 500000 visiteurs dont une bonne
moitié d'étrangers qui viennent
découvrir la longue histoire de la
Bourgogne
viticole alors au départ ce n'est pas un
château ici hein c'est une une
exploitation viticole qui est créée par
les moines de CO en 1110 et nous avons
devant nous la partie la plus ancienne
encore conservée aujourd'hui il s'agit
de la grange qui était un bâtiment
multifonction et ce bâtiment a été
construit en
1170 pour stocker le vin en particulier
et à l'étage il y avait une grande salle
qui servait de dortoir pour accueillir
les moines de Sô lorsqu'il venaient
travailler dans les vignes puis au fil
du temps le domaine s'est complété d'une
partie château qui est la partie
Renaissance qui est derrière nous le
domaine va rester petit et en 1170 les
moines obtiennent un privilège
c'est-à-dire que désormais ils ne
paieront plus d'impôt sur le vin qu'ils
produisent et ça sur un périmètre qui
est très précisément défini donc pour
bien marquer les choses dans le paysage
les moines vont décider de construire un
mur qui va entourer en fait le futur
Claude Vougeot donc ce mur c'est celui
qu'on aperçoit ici c'est un mur qui fait
3 km 300 de long et qui ensert 51
hectares de vigne et lorsqu'il est
construit en 1170 les moines ne
contrôlent à ce moment-là que 10
hectares à l'intérieur de ce clos et
puis petit à petit ils vont racheter ou
se faire donner progressivement
l'ensemble des terres qui se trouvent à
l'intérieur du mur pour constituer un
énorme domaine de 51 hactares le claud
[Musique]
deevouot
alors on est à la fin du 15e siècle vers
1480 à ce moment-là les moines de cito
décident de construire une cuverie de
très grande dimension pour abriter des
pressoirs en période de vendange ça
fourmillait il y avait il y avait du
monde absolument partout chacun des
pressoirs demandait entre 6 et 8
personnes pour les actionner il y a
quatre pressoirs ici donc il faut
imaginer un balai
incessante au départ les moines
produisent pour eux-mêmes mais très
rapidement les productions de vin étaent
tel que les moines ont commencé à
commercialiser ce vin dans les auberges
des environs dans les villes comme Dijon
ba nuit-sint-georges c'était des lieux
où on pouvait boire de ce
vin en
1781 le château et les vignes sont
confisqués comme biens nationaux les
vignes seront plus tard séparé et divisé
entre plusieurs propriétaires ils sont
aujourd'hui 85 à se partager
l'appellation grand cru clauoujot qui
correspond toujours exactement au
domaine fondé par les moines cisterciens
en
[Musique]
1110 les vignerons d'aujourd'hui sont
les héritiers des moines du
Moyen-Âge le village de Vaun romané tout
proche du château du claudeevougeot
abrite le domaine qui possède le plus
grand nombre de grands crus de toute la
Bourgogne véritable icône de la
viticulture mondiale le domaine de la
roman et
[Musique]
Conti
Aubert de Villen cohéritier du domaine a
porté le projet qui a abouti en 2015 au
classement des climats de Bourgogne au
patrimoine culturel mondial de
l'humanité nous sommes ici en plein cœur
ce qu'on appelle un climat en Bourgogne
c'est la rom Conti ces limites vous les
vous les voyez y cette limite de ce ce
petit mur ici le mur là-bas C zigzag
vert que vous voyez là et la petite
route en terre qui est là-bas juste à
côté de la Croix un climat c'est c'est
un vin c'est une une parcelle de vigne
qui est qui a une certaine superficie
des limites qui sont inscrites dans le
marbre des
appellations qui a un nom et qui fait un
vin qui a un goût spécifique particulier
que les amateurs reconnaissent et
recherchent la plupart des plus grands
vins en Bourgogne se trouve dans cette
dans ce secteur de la côte où la pente
s'amortit et devient non pas plate mais
avec une pente très douce la rom Conti
elle elle est en plein milieu de ce
secteur privilégié et c'est certainement
une des raisons de la qualité du
vin en obtenant la reconnaissance de
l'UNESCO Aubert de Villen a voulu
préserver cet héritage précieux et
fragile laissé par les générations
passées et regardé aujourd'hui comme un
modèle au niveau
mondial
[Musique]
ici nous sommes dans une cave d'élevage
qui est très ancienne typique des caves
d'élevage en
Bourgogne dans une philosophie de climat
de terroir une viticulture de terroir
tous les vignerons se rejoignent pour
dire qu'il faut faire un élevage qui
soit le moins interventionniste possible
comme on dit c'est-à-dire qui qui laisse
au vin la capacité de se développer
comme il l'entend il est difficile
d'être simple mais je pense que c'est
vraiment la clé pour faire des des très
grands vins c'est la simplicité au
niveau de la vénification comme au
niveau de
[Musique]
l'élevage les grands cru comme ceux
élevés dans ces fus représentent 1 % de
la production totale de la Bourgogne
cette rareté explique en partie les prix
vertigineux atteints par certaines
bouteilles dont celles de la romané
Conti vendu plus de 1500 € la bouteille
à des clients triés sur le
volet je peux vous risquer une petite
anecdote à l'époque où le futur
président du Brésil le fameux Loula
faisait sa campagne j'ai reçu un coup de
fil d'un journaliste brésilien qui me
demandait est-ce que vous savez que les
partisans de Loula ont créé un site
d'internet qui s'appelle roman et Conti
paratodos qui veut dire romain les Conti
pour tous et pourquoi il m'ont dit parce
que Loula a été vu dans un restaurant
buvant une bouteille de roman et Conti
ses adversaires ont dit mais comment
estce qu'un candidat socialiste peut
boire de la roman et Conti donc ces
partisans dit nous ce qu'on veut c'est
pas que tout le monde soit pauvre que
tout le monde soit riche et boive de la
roman Conti alors il m'a demandé mais
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez je lui
ditcôté ce que j'en pense c'est qu'on
peut faire en tout et pour tout que 6000
bouteilles maximum de Romain les Conti
donc il en aura jamais pour
tous suivre la route des Grands cru
c'est aussi prendre son temps musarder
au bord des vignes et l'occasion de
goûter à la gastronomie
locale Mathieu maoyer est un enfant du
pays il y a 13 ans il a installé son
restaurant le MIM dans le village de
chambolini en plein cœur de la route des
Grand Cru un endroit stratégique même si
sa cuisine se permet parfois des
incartades avec la tradition
bourgignonne les asperge blan sil vous
plaît ça bien dans
l'au
moi ce que j'adore cuisiner c'est le
cochon voilà le cochon de de a du du
groin jusqu'à la queue les pieds aussi
ça permet de faire décourvrir aux gens
des choses qu'on cuisine plus
ou qu'on n pas l'habitude de de cuisiner
on va
dire mais est-ce que cuisiner avec des
grands crus cela demande un soin
particulier ah il faut surtout faire
attention de pas avoir des pas avoir des
plaques qui puissent envahir trop le vin
on va dire
trop trop prendre le dessus par rapport
au vin surtout comme un vin comme
chambol mini c'est un vin qui est quand
même sur la finesse donc faut toujours
faire attention à ce genre de choses
Damien tu en est où dans ton rangement
de cave il me reste quelques bouteille
et après je suis en place d'accord ok je
te donne un petit coup de main le
restaurant de Mathieu possède l'une des
plus belles cartes de grand cru de la
route mais pour Damien Gelot son
sommelier la partie n'est pas toujours
facile
alors être au cœur de la route des
Grands cru c'est un avantage qui fait
que il y a énormément de passages mais
de très grands amateurs de vin ce qui
peut aussi être une certaine pression
puisqu'ils ont des attentes assez
précises d'où les 650 références sur la
carte permanente tout en essayant de
l'enrichir tous les ans de 10 à 20
références
supplémentaires c'est jamais facile
d'avoir des grands crus c'est une
production qui est très petite demandé
dans le M m entier c'est un long travail
de confiance aussi avec les viticulteurs
mais c'est toujours en petite quantité
pour certaines par trois pour d'autres
seulement par une bouteille par an donc
non non c'est pas plus facile pour nous
que pour nos voisins de B ou ou de Chaab
pour avoir ces grands crus c'est
l'armoire trésor puisque on peut y voir
certains grands cru de la Bourgogne bien
sûr pas tous mon préféré Deon romané on
ne le présente plus
aujourd'hui qui est tout simplement la
romané Conti n'en a pas tous les ans on
en a une tous les 3 ans je pense qu'on
aura peut-être la chance d'en avoir une
seconde cette année pour vous donner un
ord d'idée cette bouteille sur la carte
à voisine les 10000
€ là vous emmenz deux Carpo J on se
dépêche les de Saint-Jacques après deux
asperges allez on y
va le brocoli on y va
aussi allez on y va pour les deux
carpacho allez on
à mi-parcours de son trajet la route des
Grands cru abandonne la côte de nuit ses
cru rouges légendaires et son Pinau noir
pour entrer dans la côte de B presque
exclusivement dédié au vin blanc et au
chardonnis bone capitale des vins de
Bourgogne regorge de monuments
historiques datant du Moyen-Âge dont les
célèbres hospices de Ba pour yorri le
beau le monument représente une étape
incontournable nous nous trouvons au
centre de l'Hôtel Dieu qui fait partie
des hospices de baau et qui a été créé
en 1443 par le chancelier du duc de
Bourgogne Philippe lebond ce chancelier
n'était autre que Nicolas Rolin Nicolas
Rolin décide de créer un hôpital nous
sommes à la fin de la guerre de 100 ans
et 3/4 de la population bonoise est
formée
d'indigens on va non seulement soigner
ces personnes mais aussi et surtout les
nourrir c'est dans cette cour au toit
vernissé et dans la salle des pauvres
toutes proche qu'on été tourné en 1966
quelquesunes des scènes cultes du film
La grande vadrouille qui fut longtemps
le plus gros succès du cinéma français
alors nous voilà ici au cœur de la salle
des pauvres c'est dans cette salle
qu'était soigné les malades à l'Hôtel
Dieu les dimensions de cette salle sont
exceptionnels 46 m de long 14 m de large
et surtout 16 m de hauteur l'ensemble
des lit de part et d'autre était dirigé
en direction de cette chapelle ce qui
permettait au malades de participer aux
offices
religieux
[Musique]
B abrite de nombreux monuments médiévaux
prestigieux mais une partie de ces
trésors se cache aussi sous terre
Véronique Drouin responsable de la
vénification et de l'élevage des vins de
la Maison du même nom et l'héritière
d'un patrimoine architectural souterrain
exceptionnel alors nous nous trouvons
dans l'ancienne cuverie de la Collégiale
Notre-Dame donc un bâtiment du 13e
siècle contemporain de l'église donc
construit fin 12e début 13e donc c'était
le lieu de travail des moines qui c'est
ici qui faisaient leur vin ils avaient
un joli patrimoine viticool et donc ils
avaient besoin d'un endroit pour
viinifier donc la prière et le travail
se faisait ici derrière moi un
magnifique vestige du 16e siècle ce
pressoir dit à perroquet donc c'est un
pressoir qui on pense servi environ 200
ans et puis en 19 1980 mon père a eu
cette idée de remettre en activité ce
pressoir qui avait été en sommeil
pendant 200 ans le système est très
ingénieux et très simple très efficace
et ne requiert aucune électricité en
tournant cette roue voilà et alors ce
pressoirchante etcraque c'est magnifique
donc la roue tourne et fait descendre
cette poute principale qu'on appelle un
mouton qui vient presser les raisins qui
au préalable évidemment ont été posés
sur ce plateau et sur lesquels on a mis
ses planches et ses poutres et donc en
abaissant cette grosse poutre va presser
le jus va s'écouler retomber ici le jus
qu'on va mettre en fu et quand on
imagine l'âge de ces bois parce que le
pressoir est de 1570 mais si on VO par
exemple la poutre qui est là-haut
l'arbre qui était du chîne devait avoir
environ 300 ans donc on imagine bien
qu'une partie des pièces de ce pressoir
a peut-être connu
Charlemagne maintenant nous nous
trouvons sous le vieux Assir dans la
cave du 13e alors c'est une des très
vieilles caves de la ville de boun donc
c'est ici que les chanoanes élevaient
leur vin donc ils en tenaient mettaient
en Fû et puis les vins restaient ici
jusqu'à jusqu'à la mise alors pas en
bouteille à l'époque mais je pense que
la consommation était quand même assez
rapide à l'époque des moines et puis il
y avait pas de commercialisation des
vins c'est des très très bonnes caves
d'élevage elles sont toujours à
température assez égal elles ont une
humidité parfaite il y a pas de métro il
y a pas de tram donc il y a aucune
vibration dans ces caves c'est très
serein
ici moi je trouve qu'on a la chance de
travailler avec multiplicité de terroirs
ça c'est un peu le mystère et la
complexité de la Bourgogne mais en même
temps pour nous c'est un travail
extraordinaire que d'essayer de révéler
chacun de ces terroirs puisque voilà on
parle de nos climats de nos lieux dit
chacun de ces vins représente une petite
entité donc c'est vrai que notre travail
au fond c'est d'apprendre t ces climats
mais ça prend une vie et on les connaît
même pas tous à la fin de notre vie mais
à force de de déguster et de parler aux
anciens à ceux qui ont eu l'expérience
qui ont vinifié on va apprendre que bah
le bonne grève voilà la caractéristique
d'un bon grève c'est ces vin un petit
peu
structuré on va déguster le cort en
Charlemagne malgré le fait que le vin
soit jeune on a déjà une complexité
aromatique qui n'est pas juste sur un
fruit ou une fleur et ça c'est un petit
peu la raison de cette classification de
nos vin de Bourgogne c'està dire qu'un
Bourgogne délicieux très très fruité
très frin grand mais peut-être un petit
peu monodimensionnel et là quand on va
monter dans la hiérarchie c'està-dire
vers les premiers et les grands crus on
va avoir une palette aromatique beaucoup
plus complexe c'est la raison pour
laquelle ces vignl ont été classé en
grand cru parce que c'est pas juste
cette année mais c'était il y a 10 ans
il y a 20 ans il y a 100 ans il y a 1000
ans quand les moines ont commencé en
fait à délimiter les zones qu'ils
estimaient les meilleurs il y avait déjà
cette complexité dans les
[Musique]
vins à la sortie de B nous avons
abandonné temporairement notre traction
pour une balade à vélo à travers les
vignes un moyen ludique légèrement
sportif et totalement écolo de partir à
la découverte des villages emblématiques
de la côte comme pomard Volny ou murceau
et de profiter du
paysage regardez on va vers la petite
Cabotte ah c'est quoi une Cabotte un
refuge de vigneron une garçonnière si tu
préfères alors vous faites attention
parce que là il faut pas se cogner la
tête
allez-y ah c'est une cabote qui a à peu
près 2 300 bon on sait pas trop daté
voir plus hein c'est que de la pierre
sèche et donc c'était utilisé bah pour
faire un petit break quand il pleut
quand il fait chaud le vigneron était
heureux de s'arrêter ici et puis
également ça permettait de stocker un
petit peu de
matériel he les clos ici vous imaginez
he ça prend le soleil ça absorbe la
chaleur qui est restitué pendant la nuit
donc du coup ça donne une espèce de de
de
microatmosphère au sein du Clos la
maturation du raisin est meilleure dans
un clos
[Musique]
ouais on va faire une pose
ici on fait du vélo on découvre le
vignoble et surtout c'est aussi souvent
pour ça que les gens viennent on va
déguster du vin on visite les caves on
visite la cuverie hein donc ça permet
d'avoir une vision assez globale de la à
Bourgogne puisqu'on voit les choses
d'une manière beaucoup plus explicite on
a le temps de s'arrêter de sentir de
voir on a beaucoup de clientèle
étrangère la clientèle américaine qui
adore ce genre d'activité on a les
Canadiens les Australiens les Asiatiques
viennent les Européens sont là et le
vélo pour moi c'est imposé comme le
moyen idéal voilà donc je vous invite à
venir prendre un
verre
voilà à la
vre
[Musique]
la dernière portion de la route des
Grands cru réserve encore un ultime
trésor de la Bourgogne
viticole ici nous sommes au cœur du
Triangle d'Or lorsque l'on parle du
Triangle d'Or on parle des plus grands
vin blancs secs du monde avec notamment
l'emblématique montraachet qui se trouve
entre trois villages à l'intersection de
trois villages le village de mursau au
nord du Triangle d'Or culini Montrachet
et aussi Chassagne
montchet le montraché dont Alexandre
Duma disait qu'il fallait le boire à
genoux et la tête découverte appartient
à l'élite des plus grands vins blancs du
monde ces vins inaccessibles produit en
très petite quantité et recherché par la
terre entière les 7 hectares 99 qui le
produisent sont presque devenus un lieu
de
pèlerinage
les touristes qu' viennent de l'Hexagone
ou qu'il viennent du monde entier quand
ils ont eu la chance de traverser les
villages dont ils ont entendu parler
tant de fois quand ils ont eu la chance
de sillonner les vignes de les caresser
du regard de déguster les vins de
pénétrer dans les caves tout ça
participe au souvenirs qu'ils vont en
avoir et lorsqu'ils rentent il ne
déguste plus des vin de Bourgogne mais
déguste des parcelles de
souvenirs notre voyage aussi se termine
ici près du petit village de
Santen coffre les yeux et la bouche
rempl de souvenirs avec une envie folle
de revenir
bientôt